it has been a deadly year on our
roadways traffic fatalities are up at
least 30 percent statewide compared to
last year
safety advocates are sounding the alarm
they want you to pay attention
on the roads and to their message as
they work to put an end to this alarming
trend
hector mejia shows us what you need to
know
hey there and advocates say it's
everyone's responsibility to make sure
we make it home
safely not just the drivers and a group
got together here earlier this morning
inside university medical center this is
where trauma patients get seen after a
crash
it's also nevada's only pediatric trauma
center
unlv's vulnerable road users project
brought together law enforcement
agencies along with doctors to talk
about recent traffic fatalities
monday night two-year-old miguel angel
morales was killed by an suv while
crossing the road
in the northeast valley in the five
weeks since may 1st
at least 20 people died on our roadways
in clark county
more than half were pedestrians
motorcyclists
cyclists and moped riders were also part
of the tragedy
this morning we also heard from people
who see this firsthand
almost on a daily basis while it is very
sad
to see injured adults and adults that
die
you can only imagine what it's like to
see children die
and to talk with their parents that they
have lost
their loved one who should have had
a normal long life every patient i see
woke up in the morning and thought it
was going to be a normal day
it's very sad to hear and dr deborah
kohls is pleading to parents please
restrain your child with a seat belt or
car seat when they're in the car with
you
also if you're on a bicycle or
motorcycle please remember to wear your
helmet
we also heard from metro's fatal detail
team they said so far this year they've
worked on 59 fatalities
that number was 41 last year reporting
outside umc hector mejia
8 news now